we always buy these fascinating stories
about porn habit in the united state
what state is watching what
a lot of weird stuff in the south
usually but we vow are based on
political partisanship
that democrats versus republicans what
porn there watching and this was
a study done by Buzby they teamed up
with the fine folks over at pornhub dot
com
and the let's see what they found out so
democrats are watching more porn the
Republic and I was surprised we think
the republicans are hiding
in their room watching the we're bored
and they are just a teeny bit late just
that it's not a huge This is page views
per capita a over twelve month study
there's a 13 percent difference for
democrats are watching thirteen-percent
a more porn let's look at the top raid
This is page views per capita we have
someone from Kansas added that make you
feel
proud very very proud yeah I hear that
about this
what let linemen what do you think's
going on again just that they're
watching
so much but I don't know I was actually
shocked by this because
I love the good people I'll the great
state of Kansas the bread basket the
Great Plains if you will
yeah it is where I hail from geographic
center in the United States of America
yeah
all right there literally at the
Heartland yeah they cannot I'm
I know but many Kansans that up
pretty up good bring glory for so
this actually almost like they don't get
out a lot because they're too busy
care kit porn and I yeah I was actually
really surprised by this
I don't I don't think there's really
anything wrong with you know people
watching porn so if they have my people
want to do that I think god bless I also
don't think there's anything I would
like to but let's look at the top we
stayed the course boo means democratic
if you're in this game
Nevada know some beer at Harry Reid
he so boring that these people feel like
they need boring or super hot
and a
not a mere the Illinois Colorado
Massachusetts
et cetera et cetera I the Colorado
Colorado
which inexplicably board which just that
we're
it doesn't make announced yesterday
right Colorado Park and is that nobody
really
inhabit yet in the park colorado that
nobody thinks is cholera outbreak that
connection
you got a guy like 30 miles Colorado for
easier for him out
yet and that but that but I think you're
in Kansas
in results it's very cold its
its black there's nothing to stop the
wind in the call that so people stay and
watch porn and then when it's not cold
when it's nice out
you go outside and you're like on this
topic another
I go back go back to cut yeah
but Colorado surprise because it's a you
know
be outdoors vigorous and exciting
American West
are you a surprise the democrats watch
more porn even though it's only thirteen
percent
there's only so much you can bring it
out of studies like this but
isn't it surprising I seem like the
first anywhere you think that we're
going to turn out the concert was much
more didn't get out that way
Pamela surprise because it turns out to
be we think would watch more porn
anymore sorta
sexually progress and open are the
people who watch for rather
I don't really think it's the worst
right the other it will you're right we
thought by I think we all thought this
is going to come out like
repression and like i hahaha right like
it turns out you know there's probably
some truth if your little more liberal
your problem or
liberal with the right Joyce did you
know that you know a lot of us
believe in say and ran on Young Turks
shows all the time that
that you know I think that most anti-gay
congressman the most rightly anti gay
people are probably secretly gay
I really don't know why I seldom bother
I don't think
I just think they're their on secretly
hateful yeah I don't care
act I don't think there some way I don't
think they go home and you loftier
ambitions
I do I just think they're bad people I
don't think they're tryna I don't think
you're hiding something I just don't
know who they are
but there's a lot that can we at least
pretend that the majority
I'll the cans and stay at home and
yanking it to porn are all in the
Westboro Baptist Church compound naw
that would be nice to the for the
purposes of this segment we sure can we
can hear
but we have to I'd be remiss if we
didn't talk about independence in a
point study about is what do you think
the independents are they watching a lot
a point there clearly
after being alone there they got here
they have every right now
yeah their right and their they're just
there right there
not as much as the democrats not as
little as the Republic yet about you
when I bet there
as much as the democrats because there's
some degree of repression happening with
republicans it just won't let them do it
even in the privacy but they're
independent they don't care what you
think they'll do whatever they want
they'll sit there all day and
independents are basically
got worse and unwilling to make an
important decision
us alright